Wir kämpfen uns hier hoch,
haben fast keine Zeit,
etwas zu denken.
Dort unten ist die Rettung,
weil ein Stein hinuntergefallen ist.
Wir schauen einfach,
dass wir nach oben kommen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Sommer 2020.
Mein Ziel: das legendäre Matterhorn.
Kein anderer Berg dieser Welt
übt sowohl auf Kletterer
als auch auf Touristen
solch eine Magie aus.
Obwohl ich die Gefahren
dieses Bergs kenne, will ich da hoch.
* Sanfte Musik *
In der Hörnlihütte auf 3'200 m ü.M.
treffe ich Anjan Truffer,
meinen Bergführer.
Grüezi, grüezi.
- Ciao, Matthias.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke.
Der Walliser
war schon über 200-mal ganz oben
und als Chef der Bergrettung kennt er
den Berg so gut wie kaum ein Zweiter.
Was braucht es,
damit man hinaufkommt?
Gute Kondition
ist sicher das Wichtigste.
Es ist ein anstrengender Berg.
Technisch
ist es nicht wahnsinnig schwierig.
Zum Klettern
gibt es zweimal kurz eine 4,
dort kann der Bergführer helfen.
Den Rest nennen wir Gämsgelände.
Dort muss man einfach fit sein.
Denn es ist immer schwierig,
einen guten Rhythmus zu finden.
Die Tritte
sind immer unterschiedlich.
Und es ist hoch,
man ist auf fast 4'500 m ü.M.
Sich etwas zu akklimatisieren,
ist auch gut.
Wie viele Unfälle gibt es?
Gemäss Statistiken
der letzten 40 Jahre
hatten wir ca. sechs Tote
pro Sommer.
Das ist viel.
- Das ist schon viel.
Im internationalen Vergleich,
mit anderen Bergen?
International verglichen ist
das Matterhorn statistisch gesehen
der tödlichste Berg.
Wir haben seit der Erstbesteigung
bis jetzt fast 600 Tote.
Das ist viel.
Der tödlichste Berg -
ein Superlativ, auf den in Zermatt
jeder gerne verzichten würde.
Wärst du dafür,
dass man nur mit Führer hinaufdarf?
Ja, wenn ich etwas zu sagen hätte,
würde ich das sagen.
Jedenfalls auf der Normalroute.
Ist das keine Bevormundung
des Alpinisten?
Jein. Klar ist es
eine gewisse Bevormundung.
Aber wenn man sieht, wie es in
anderen Ländern gehandhabt wird ...
Entweder braucht man ein Permis
oder darf nur mit Bergführer hinauf,
wie in gewissen Nationalparks
in Amerika.
Das ist von der Sicherheit her
sicher nicht schlecht,
wenn man sieht,
wie viele Unfälle passieren.
Und höchst wenige mit Bergführern -
ich klopfe auf Holz.
Mit welchem Gefühl
gehst du an diesen Berg?
Es ist ein superschöner Berg
und eine megacoole Bergtour.
Es ist von allem etwas dabei,
ist schön zum Klettern.
Es ist kein Gerümpelhaufen,
wie viele denken -
wenn man den Weg kennt.
Du siehst es morgen:
Es ist nicht so schlecht.
Also, wollen wir das Material kontrollieren?
So, da sind wir.
Friedlich.
Was habe ich alles dabei?
Natürlich Kameraequipment. - Jawohl.
Damit wir das Ganze auf Bild festhalten können. - Das ist doch super.
Das wird dich wohl nicht so sehr interessieren.
Schau mal her: Ein Steigeisen.
Du hast diese Schuhe und diese Steigeisen schon einmal benutzt?
Es sind nicht die besten, aber für hier rauf wird es reichen. - Es wird reichen
Hat es viel Schnee oben? Braucht man sie?
Ja, oben wirst du sie schon brauchen.
Ab der Schulter gehen wir mit den Steigeisen weiter.
Aber es hat gute Tritte. - Nein, ich laufe noch gerne mit Steigeisen.
Anjan Truffer weiss, dass ich ein geübter Berggänger bin
und scheint mit meinem Material zufrieden zu sein.
Etwas zu trinken habe ich dabei. - Das ist gut.
Wie viel zu trinken brauchst du in der Regel?
Das wird schon reichen. - Ja ja.
Ich habe ansonsten auch noch Wasser dabei. Dann kannst du von mir nehmen.
Den Klettergurt ziehe ich bereits zum Frühstück an, oder?
Am Morgen ist es am besten, wenn du aufstehst, dich komplett fertig anziehst und bereit machst.
So dass wir nach dem Frühstück um 20 nach mit den Anderen gleich gehen können.
Von der Hörnlihütte starten
üblicherweise 130 Personen pro Tag
Richtung Gipfel.
Im Corona-Sommer 2020
ist es knapp die Hälfte.
Am Berg ist es ruhig wie selten.
Wo ist der Einstieg? Wo geht es hoch?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, du!
Wir folgen dann jemandem.
Folgen wir jemandem?
- Nein, Spass beiseite.
Siehst du dort die Madonna,
die schwarze Gottesstatue?
Ah, ja.
Dann siehst du rechts oben ein Band,
das zurückkommt.- Ja.
Dort hat es zwei, drei Fixseile,
dann geht es links um die Ecke.
Dann geht es durch die Geröllfelder
nach hinten Richtung erstes Couloir.
Ab der Hörnlihütte verläuft die
Normalroute zuerst in der Ostflanke
bis zur Notschlafstelle Solvay
auf 4'000 m.
Dann folgt die Tour dem Hörnligrat
bis aufs Matterhorn auf 4'478 m ü.M.
Der Hörnligrat ist mit Abstand
der meistbegangene Grat, oder?- Ja.
Der Hörnligrat und dann dahinter noch der Liongrat, der wird auch viel begangen.
Freust du dich?
- Ja, ja. Gesunde Anspannung.
Ich auch.
Dann sind wir zu zweit. Gut!
- Gut.
Also, viva!- Auf morgen,
auf eine schöne Tour, Matthias.
Ich freue mich.
- Gut.- Danke.
Er, der Walliser, muss es wissen:
Ein Glas Rotwein am Vorabend
scheint nicht zu schaden.
Ich selber wäre wohl nicht
auf die Idee gekommen.
Aber Anjan Truffers Lockerheit
wirkt beruhigend.
Man vergisst schnell, dass so viel
Tragik mit diesem Berg verbunden ist.
Zu viel hat er schon erlebt
an diesem, seinem Berg.
Genau vor einem Jahr
war er als Bergretter im Einsatz,
als er zwei Berggänger
nur noch tot bergen konnte.
Anhand älterer Aufnahmen
versucht er mir
den Unfallhergang zu schildern.
Jetzt siehst du es perfekt:
Der ganze Teil hier
ist heruntergefallen.
Die Augenzeugen,
die unten zugeschaut haben, sagten,
er sei herausgekommen
und in 1'000 Stücke zersprungen.
Schon beim Herauskommen?
- Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Denn darunter ...
Es war um 9 Uhr morgens,
da sind die Seile voller Leute.
Laut den Personen, die kletterten,
seilte hier oben ein Bergführer
einen Gast ab.
Er hatte einen angehängt,
das ist nicht abnormal.
Das tun wir immer, auch morgen.
Unten kletterten gleichzeitig
vier am Seil.
An und für sich macht das nichts.
Aber vielleicht war das
das Zünglein an der Waage.
Wenn ich das anschaue ...
Du gehörst zu den Jungs, die
diese Seile installiert haben.- Ja.
Kann man nicht sagen, ihr habt es
nicht richtig eingeschätzt?
Nein, sicher nicht.
Wir liessen es sofort abklären.
Der Fels
ist seit der Erstbesteigung so.
Es hat sich nichts verändert.
Der Bohrer darauf -
ich weiss nicht, von wann der ist -
ist mind. 50 Jahre drauf,
wenn nicht länger.
Im Endeffekt hat jeder Bergsteiger,
der hier hinaufgeht,
eine gewisse Eigenverantwortung.
Man geht mit einem gewissen
Restrisiko in die Berge.
Man kann mit den besten Experten
und Geologen spekulieren.
Keiner gibt einem
eine 100%ige Antwort,
was sein könnte,
was war oder was wird.
Das war nicht schön.
Der Bergführer hat zwei
kleine Kinder, wie meine Kinder.
Man beginnt schon nachzudenken.
Das könnte auch man selbst sein.
Aber klar: Keiner will sich
vorstellen, der nächste zu sein.
Jeder hat immer das Gefühl,
er sei am sichersten unterwegs,
er mache es am besten.
Das muss auch so sein.
Wenn ich morgen hier oben das Gefühl
hätte: "Uh!", ginge ich nach Hause.
Sag mir, wenn du dieses Gefühl
hast.- Ja, du auch.
* Matthias lacht. *
Es wird eine Herausforderung.
Auf der Terrasse
treffe ich einen Südkoreaner,
der dasselbe Ziel hat wie ich.
Gehst du morgen auch hoch?
- Vielleicht.
Wird es dein erstes Mal?
- Ja.
Was ist dein Eindruck?
Das ist mein Traum
seit der Oberstufe.
Really?
- Yeah.
Ich klettere auch.
Ich bin 73 Jahre alt.
Wow!
Das ist mein Traum.
Es genügt mir schon, wenn ich zwei
bis drei Seillängen klettern kann.
Also nicht bis zum Gipfel?
Nein, es reicht mir bereits,
den Fels mal anzufassen.
Alright, okay.
Dann wünsche ich dir
viel Erfolg morgen.
Wir sehen uns.
Den Fels wenigstens einmal berühren -
seine Worte
stehen für den Mythos Matterhorn.
In der Hütte
wird es am Abend rasch ruhiger.
Auch ich
lege mich gegen 21.30 Uhr ins Bett.
* Erhabene Klänge *
Am Horn herrscht um dieselbe Uhrzeit
noch reger Betrieb.
Zwei Teams sind im Abstieg
und erreichen die Hütte
erst gegen 1 Uhr nachts -
über 20 Std. waren sie unterwegs.
* Wecker *
Ja, da sind wir. Guten Morgen.
Da sind wir.
(Mann) Wie spät ist es?
- Jetzt ist es 3.40 Uhr.
3.40 Uhr. In 40 Min. geht es los.
Ich muss noch etwas essen,
dann können wir gehen.
Ich habe auch schon
besser geschlafen.
Beim Schlaf spüre ich die Höhe schon.
Man schläft nicht so tief
wie zu Hause.
Und die Aufregung und alles,
nicht wahr?
Man kann sie doch
nicht ganz verdrängen.
Ein GoPro-Gurt.
Daran montiere ich noch
eine kleine Cam für mich.
4.10 Uhr.
Kameramann Thomas Senf begleitet uns
mit einem weiteren Bergführer
bis auf den Gipfel.
Wir testen ein letztes Mal
unser technisches Material.
Soundcheck: one, two.
- Super.
Bist du auch nervös?
- Ja.
Zu dieser Zeit
bin ich immer verdammt nervös.
Bis wir endlich gehen können?
Noch 5 Min.
Der Start folgt klaren Regeln.
Die Tür öffnet genau um 4.20 Uhr
und die Reihenfolge der Teams
wird am Vorabend
von den Bergführern festgelegt.
Wie ist die Hierarchie?
Wie gesagt: locals.
- Die dürfen zuerst?
Die, die oft gehen.
Dann schätzt man die Gäste ab.
Man sieht, wenn jemand
jung und gut ist - die Gämsen.
Es hat keinen Sinn,
wenn die Langsamen zuvorderst sind.
Das würde alles ...
Ich kann mir also
einen Vorteil verschaffen,
wenn ich mit einem local gehe?
- Das ist richtig.
Ich muss ja auch
einen gewissen Vorteil haben.
Gehen wir?
- Ist gut.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Tschüss zusammen! Macht's gut.
- Viel Erfolg, tschüss.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Ich habe Glück mit meinem Walliser.
Wir sind das zweite Team.
Die erfahrenen Bergführer vorneweg
kennen den Weg
auch in der Nacht problemlos
und vermeiden damit,
dass sich die Bergsteiger
im losen Gestein verirren.
Dies wird sonst zu einer grossen
Gefahr für die nachfolgenden Teams,
die von losgetretenem Geröll
getroffen werden könnten.
Siehst du, Matthias?
Hier hat es Eisentritte.- Ja.
Sobald das Seil gespannt ist,
kannst du kommen.
Schön langsam, genau.
Nimm von Anfang an kleine Tritte.
Jetzt siehst du auch, dass es nicht
so ein Gedränge ist, wie alle sagen.
Aber wir sind auch vorne,
das ist schon ein Vorteil.
Dort vorne, rechts oben,
hat es schon Lampen.
Das sind welche,
die zu früh gegangen sind.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich früher
gestartet oder von unten gekommen.
Das sind die, die für uns
nachher ein Problem sind.
Wegen dem Steinschlag, weisst du.
Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Warte, warte, warte!
- Wir können doch jetzt hoch, oder?
Ja, sicher. Um wie viel Uhr
seid ihr gestartet?
Wir sind vom Schwarzsee aus
gestartet.
Schon gut. Schönen Tag.
So forsch kenne ich Anjan
bis jetzt gar nicht.
Aber ihm scheint es
keine Mühe zu bereiten,
die Rangordnung am Berg
ohne Pardon zu bestimmen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik,
schweres Atmen *
Alles gut bei dir Matthias?
Bis jetzt ist es schön. Die Stirnlampe kann ich jetzt abnehmen, oder?
Ja, die kannst du wegnehmen.
Die brauchen wir hoffentlich heute nicht mehr.
Für mich ist das einmalig.
Geniesst du das auch?
Sehr.
Tage wie heute, wenn es so ruhig ist und das Wetter mit solch super Verhältnissen...
Für diejenigen, die sich fragen, wie solche Sachen gefilmt werden:
Ein geländegängiger Kameramann, der doppelt so fit ist wie der Reporter.
Das hilft, auch die Kamera zu tragen.
Letztendlich sind wir auch einfach unterwegs. Was hast du alles dabei?
Nur eine kleine Kamera für die Nacht und als Backup. Und diese hier habe ich auch dabei.
Damit hat es sich.
Ich habe noch eine GoPro dabei.
Eine Drohne haben wir auch noch. - Stimmt eine Drohne haben wir auch noch dabei.
Eine Drohne und ein paar Drogen.
*lachen*
Alles gut? - Alles gut.
Gut,
du kannst aushängen und klettern.
Jawohl, ich komme.
Schön langsam. Genau.
Links kannst du austreten
beim schönen Tritt. Super.
Siehst du,
jetzt sind wir schon bei der Solvay.
4'000 m.
Super, was?
Geht es dir gut?
- Tipptopp.
Mal schauen.
Rechts ist ein schöner Griff.
Du kannst nach links klettern.
Er kennt jeden Griff,
das ist unglaublich.
(Lachend) Für mich nicht erklärbar.
Ist gut.
Wie ist es so?
Kannst du es geniessen?
Absolut. Mega.
- Klettern!
Jetzt jammert er schon.
Es ist mega.
Gerade im Dunkeln
war es richtig meditativ.
Ich konnte ihm einfach folgen
und musste nicht viel nachdenken.
Jetzt hätte ich aufpassen müssen.
Wo war dieser Griff?
Irgendwo gab es hier
einen guten Griff. Ah, hier.
* Ächzen *
* Sanfte Streichmusik *
Ja, super.
* Die Musik schwillt an. *
Jetzt sind wir ...
- ... nicht ganz 2 1/2 Std.
... 2 1/2 Std. unterwegs.
- Ja.
Bist du von der Zeit her zufrieden?
- Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Noch nicht zu spät?
- Schneller kann es immer sein.
Das ist so.
Für mich ist es genau richtig.
Wir machen kein Rennen.
Obwohl - das hat sich heute Morgen
beim ersten Überholmanöver
anders angefühlt.
Als wir die zwei Tessiner
oder Italiener überholt haben,
bist du ihnen einfach
voll vorne reingestiegen.
Ja. Sie lassen dich nicht vorbei.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Aber woher nimmst du das Recht,
zu sagen ...
Sie kennen den Weg nicht.
- Siehst du das sofort?
Das hat man schon
von 100 m Entfernung gesehen.
Erstens sind sie zu früh gestartet
oder vom Schwarzsee gekommen.
Dann sind sie allen im Weg.
Und beim nächsten Couloir
sind sie neben den Weg,
haben Steinschlag
und wir sind darunter.
Für mich wirkte es so:
"Ich bin der Chef am Berg."
Nein. Es geht um unsere Sicherheit.
Wenn man einige Male mit Gästen
hier hinauf- und hinuntergeht
und hier arbeitet, ist es
nicht dasselbe wie für jemanden,
der einmal im Leben
mit einem Freund hinaufgeht.
Wo sind wir hier?
- Da ist ein Fixseil.
Gleich kommen wir zum Kreuzsatz,
wo der Unfall war.
Ah, sind wir schon hier?
- Ja.
Ist das für dich völlig entspannt?
Ja, tipptopp, geht super.
- (Lachend) Ja.
Oder hast du hier
irgendwelche Bedenken?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Jetzt im Moment
fühle ich mich pudelwohl.
Lassen wir Senf wieder voraus.
- Ja.
Siehst du, unten ist gerade
eine Rettung im Gang.- Ah, ja.
Vorher
gab es ziemlichen Steinschlag.
Jetzt habe ich gesehen,
dass sie den Rettungsspezialisten
abgesetzt haben.
Das wäre dein Job, wenn du heute
nicht mit mir hier wärst?
Ja, wäre ich nicht mit dir hier,
wäre ich dort.
Hast du eine Ahnung,
warum das passiert ist?
Ich habe nur
den Steinschlag gesehen.
Ob das etwas damit zu tun hat
oder nicht, ist Spekulation.
Suchen sie dort jemanden?
Ich glaube, der
Rettungsspezialist ist dort oben.
Vielleicht ist dort noch jemand.
Wir hoffen natürlich nicht,
dass auch unten jemand ist.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ja, super, Matthias! Tipptopp.
Das war dieser Block letztes Jahr.
- Ah, hier brach er raus.
Das war hier?
- Ja.
Es ist schon verrückt, oder?
Viel sinnbildlicher
könnte es nicht sein.
Wir kämpfen uns hier hoch,
haben fast keine Zeit,
etwas zu denken.
Dort unten ist die Rettung,
weil ein Stein hinuntergefallen ist.
Wir schauen einfach,
dass wir nach oben kommen.
Momentan bleibt überhaupt keine Zeit.
* Ächzen *
Nach gut 3 Std.
lassen wir die Fixseile hinter uns
und der Gipfel
rückt in greifbare Nähe.
* Erhabene Streichmusik *
Gut gemacht, gratuliere.
- Gleichfalls.
Ein super Tag.
Mega Weitsicht,
keine Wolken weit und breit.
* Erhabene Streich- und Blasmusik *
Wunderbar, was?
Hey!
- Matthias!
Vielen Dank!
- Bravo!
War verdammt cool!
- Super.
Jetzt musst du mich
nur noch hinunterbringen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir Halbzeit. Aber
toll, ein megacooler Tag, nicht?
Bis jetzt schon.
- Kaum Leute.
Kameramann?
- Sackstark.
Super.
- Sackstark, du hast es geschafft.
Ruhe und Erhabenheit
auf dem Matterhorn
sind allerdings eine Illusion.
50 weitere Teams
drängen nun auf den Gipfel,
während wir uns
auf den Rückweg machen.
Normalerweise wartet man drüben.
Man lässt die Leute vom Gipfel.
(Frau) Extrême, extrême.
* Klopfen *
(Ächzend) Tipptopp.
Was am Matterhorn auch speziell ist,
ist der Abstieg.
Er ist ebenso heikel
oder anstrengend wie der Aufstieg.
* Ächzen *
Jetzt habe ich
die Kampflinie genommen.
Wie bitte?
- Ich bin etwas direkt gegangen.
Gut, kein Problem.
- Schon gut.
Ist das schlau?
- Wie bitte?
Ist das schlau, was ich mache?
- Jawohl, so ist es gut.
Genau. Einfach hier gut festhalten.
Was ist deine Strategie
beim Hinuntergehen?- Vollgas.
Du machst dir keine Freunde am Berg.
- Man muss immer schauen.
Wenn Berufsmänner
mit Bergführern unterwegs sind,
kann man gut diskutieren.
Oft hat es Leute aus dem Ostblock
oder Asiaten,
dann kann man nicht kommunizieren.
Für diesen Abschnitt
brauchen sie 2-3 Std., wir 30 Min.
Wenn du nett sein
und auf jeden warten willst,
bist du um 16 Uhr noch hier,
dann kannst du es vergessen.
Es härtet auch ab,
wenn man so oft hier oben ist wie du.
Ja, es ist für alle dasselbe.
Aber überall,
nicht nur am Matterhorn.
Okay, ho-hopp, komm!
Anjan legt Hand an
und zieht ihn hoch.
Ja, schau dir die mal an.
Super, gut gemacht.
Ich mache hier los.
Lass die Hand los,
ich löse schnell das Seil.
Komm hoch, dann kannst du vorbei.
Zieh! Sehr gut. Stoss dich besser
mit deinen Beinen ab.
Wie findest du das?
- Gut, tipptopp, alles gut.
Ist es kein Problem,
dass dort unten Leute stehen?
Überhaupt nicht.
Du kannst dich ins Seil hängen.
Ja, ich bin drin.
- Geh bis zum Eisenstift.
Zu welchem?
- Ich sage es dir dann.
Geh einfach links
bzw. rechts von dir.
Jawohl.
- Gut.
Gut!
Jetzt läuft's, was?
- Ja, jetzt ist Stosszeit.
Rushhour.
- Ja.
Das sind die Stellen, an denen wir
sicher nicht picknicken.
Hier gibt man etwas Gas.
Einfach straight.
- Geh hinunter.
Langsam, damit du niemandem
auf die Finger trittst.
Gut.
- Immer schön links von dir.
Willst du noch eins weiter?
- Ja, dann stehst du besser.
Ja, ist gut. Hallo.
- Hallo.
Gib noch etwas Seil!
Gut!
- Okay.
Halt dich am Seil
und beweg dich nicht.
Matthias, du kannst mein Seil
leicht einziehen.
Hier auch vorwärts hinunter?
- Jawohl, möglichst vorwärts.
Jetzt sind wir bei der Solvay.
- Hier waren wir am Morgen auch.
Es ist eigentlich keine Hütte,
sondern ein Biwak.
Wir können mal hinein, komm.
Diese Hütte ist sehr umstritten,
denn sie wird oft missbraucht.
Das ist für uns
eigentlich ein Nachteil.
Was heisst missbraucht?
Sie planen eine Tour,
schlafen hier oben
und starten am Morgen von hier.
Diese Hütte hat aber auch schon
sehr viele Menschenleben gerettet.
Ohne diese Hütte
wären viele gestorben.
Links oder rechts?
- Links.
Halten! Boah!
Gut.
- Ja, gut.
Das ging fast in die Hose.
- Ja, aber nur fast.
Es braucht nicht viel,
eine kleine Unkonzentriertheit.
Absolut.
- Und nachher ...
... bist du schon tschüss.
- Ohne Seil ist es saublöd.
Unten auf der Traverse
mit Schnee und Eis gut aufpassen.
Ist es okay, wenn ich unten ...
Ja, halt dich am Kabel,
falls du auf den Schnee gehst.
Hoppla!
Wo gehe ich hier?
- Warten!- Ja. Sorry.
Oben hinein?
- Moment. Moment!
Ich stehe schlecht.
- Wenn ich sage warten, warte.
Jetzt ist es gut.- Sonst
kündige ich die Freundschaft.
Jetzt kannst du gehen.
Wenn wir jetzt rutschen,
hängen wir einfach in der Leine.
Weisst du, was ich meine?
- Ja.
Jetzt sind wir unten.
Ciao.
- Tipptopp.
Wenn die Traversen,
die wir jetzt gegangen sind,
trocken sind, ist es einfach.
Das geht mit den Händen
in den Hosentaschen.- Ja, fast.
Aber kaum ist es etwas nass,
passieren hier viele Unfälle.
Dann stürzt man hinunter,
in die Ostwand.
Am ganzen Matterhorn
vermissen wir noch 20 Personen.
Die sind tendenziell dort unten?
- Ja, sicher die meisten.
Es ist wohl auch für
die Hinterbliebenen verdammt hart,
wenn man nicht Abschied nehmen kann.
Ja, das ist so.
Hallo!
- Hallo.- Hallo.
Alles gut?
- Alles gut. Langsam.
Willst du jetzt noch bis ganz
nach oben?- Ich denke nicht.
Ich wollte mal den Weg kennenlernen,
schauen, ob man ihn findet.
Es wird so viel geschrieben.
Aber man sieht die Steine
doch ganz gut,
die abgegriffen und abgetreten sind.
Was ist dein Eindruck?
Ist das allein machbar?- Ja.
Wenn es am Anfang schon rote Pfeile
hätte, käme fast jeder hoch.
Aber das ist kein Wanderweg.
Es ist schon
ein bisschen Bergsteigen.
V.a., wenn man hinunterkommt.
An einer Ecke war ich etwas im Fels.
Da hatte es Blutspuren.
Jemand hat sich anscheinend
verletzt.
Es gab einen Unfall.
- Ja, heute früh.
Da waren frische Blutspuren. Der
muss da irgendwo abgerutscht sein.
Er ist nicht
auf dem Hauptweg geblieben.
Und du findest den Hauptweg
ohne Probleme?
Ich kenne ihn auch nicht.
Aber ich kenne es
von anderen Bergen.
Deswegen gehe ich
nicht unbedingt geradeaus.
Ich schaue immer, ob es doch
plötzlich nach links oder hochgeht.
Und ein Bergführer wäre kein Thema?
Das wäre möglicherweise
schon ein Thema.
Aber ich bin aus Erfahrung ...
Richtig schwere Berge
mache ich nicht.- Okay.
Und hier, ohne Seil,
hast du keine Angst?
Ich habe ein Seil.
- Aber wer sichert dich?
Gibt es hier nicht auch
Eisen mit Ringen?
Es gibt immer mal wieder Ringe.
Ich denke, vom Klettern her
ist es noch im Rahmen.
Du kletterst auch gut,
das ist natürlich etwas anderes.
Dann pass mal gut auf beim Abstieg.
- Ja, pass auf.
Nicht, dass du noch ...
- Ich geh noch hoch bis zur Solvay.
Dann gehe ich langsam runter.
Langsamkeit ist das wichtigste Mass.
Alles Gute! Tschüss!
- Alles Gute!- Mach's gut, tschüss!
Das ist einfach typisch.- Solche
Leute holst du am Schluss vom Berg?
Ja, das ist genau das.
Die guten Alpinisten
haben selten ein Problem.
Aber bis der irgendwo ist,
ist der halbe Tag vorbei.
Und bis er zurück in der Hütte ist,
ist es dunkel.
Wenn man sagen könnte,
man müsse mit Bergführer gehen,
passiert das nicht.
Es würden sicher
viel weniger Unfälle passieren.
Das ist eine Tatsache.
Hallo, mein Freund.
Schönes Wetter.
- Very good weather.
Fast ein bisschen zu heiss.
Ich sollte nackt sein.
* Matthias und Anjan lachen. *
Anjan, du mit 73?
- Ja, ich gehe noch ein paar Mal.
Kommst du auch wieder mit?
- Ja, wenn ich noch kann.
Es gibt einige ältere Bergführer,
die wirklich fit sind.
Man muss die Touren evtl.
dem Fitnesslevel
oder dem technischen Level anpassen.
Aber unterwegs sein
kann man noch lange.
* Schwebende Musik *
Jetzt kannst du dich wieder nach
vorne drehen und hinunterklettern.
Hier kannst du gerade hinunter.
Schön gemütlich
über diese Treppenstufen.
Ja, ja, gemütliche Treppenstufen.
Das ist auch
eine Walliser Interpretation.
(Flüsternd) Gemütliche Treppenstufen.
Ist das das erste ...
Die Seilschaft.
- ... von heute Morgen.
Das habe ich schon wieder
halb vergessen.
Nach rund 7 Std. kommen wir heil
in der Hörnlihütte an.
Die zwei geretteten Steinschlagopfer
wurden mit mittelschweren
Kopfverletzungen ins Spital gebracht.
Der deutsche Tourist kehrt
nach einer Nacht in der Solvayhütte
am nächsten Abend zurück.
Erfolgreich überlebt. Vielen Dank.
Gratuliere.
- Danke für alles. Es war cool.
Danke dir. Ein schöner Tag.
- Es war verdammt geil.
Hunger?
- Ja.
Jetzt merke ich langsam,
dass wir heute etwas gemacht haben.
Jetzt haben wir
etwas zu essen verdient.
Und wie fühlst du dich?
- Noch gut.- Easy, oder?
Besser kann es fast nicht sein.
Du hast dich auch gut vorbereitet.
Das sieht man,
wenn jemand so fit ist.
Wir haben heute auch viele
Filmarbeiten gemacht, sind gesessen,
hatten Interviews usw.
Es war relativ locker.
- Schau jetzt!
Es gibt Essen für die Bergsteiger.
- Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Mir hat sich heute einfach
auch wieder gezeigt:
Die grösste Gefahr am Berg
ist der Mensch.- Ja.
In diesem Sinn: Viva!
- Cheers.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke dir, es war schön.